where we left off in the last video we
had set up a definite integral using the
shell method for this strange solid of
revolution so now let's just evaluate
the integral and like we've seen many
times with these types of problems we
really just have to do some some
polynomial multiplication right over
here so X -3 squared well that's pretty
straightforward that's going to be x
squared minus 6x plus 9 and we're going
to multiply that times X minus 1 so
let's do that first so multiply that
times X minus 1 and so negative 1 times
9 is negative 9 negative 1 times
negative 6 is positive 6 positive 6 X
negative 1 times x squared is negative x
squared now x times 9 is 9 x x times
negative 6x is negative 6 x squared and
then x times x squared is X to the third
X to the third and so we get we get X to
the third minus 7x squared + 15 X minus
9 and then we have 2 so we just multiply
2 X minus 3 squared times X minus 1 and
then we have to multiply that times X so
it can essentially raise the degree of
each of these things so our original
integral has simplified to or at least
this be it's easier to now to take the
antiderivative it's equal to 2 pi times
the definite integral from 1 to 3 of
this stuff times X so it's going to be
it's going to be X to the fourth X to
the fourth minus 7 X to the third power
+ 15 x squared minus 9 X and then of
course DX and I'll make the DX I'll make
in that same nice blue color now let's
just take the antiderivative so this is
going to be equal to 2 pi times the
antiderivative of all of this business
the antiderivative we're going to
evaluate it at 3 and subtract it when
it's evaluated at 1 so the
antiderivative of X to the fourth is X
to the fifth over 5 X to the fifth over
five the antiderivative
of X to the third is X to the fourth
over four and we're going to multiply
that times negative seven so it's
negative 7x to the fourth over four and
then the antiderivative of fifteen x
squared that's going to be 15 times X to
the third over 3 15 divided by 3 is 5 so
it's plus five X to the third and then
finally the antiderivative I'm running
out of colors of negative 9x that's
going to be negative nine halves x
squared negative 9x squared over two and
you can verify if you take the
derivative of this you get this business
right over here and so this is going to
be equal to this is going to be equal to
2 pi 2 pi and so let's evaluate all of
this business let's first evaluate all
of this business at 3 so when you
evaluate at 3 you have 3 to the fifth
power over 5 and I believe that's three
to the fifth is 243 but I'll verify 3 to
the third is 27 3 to the fourth is equal
to 81 3 to the fifth is 243 so this is
going to give us some hairy math to deal
with it so it's going to be 243 over 5 3
to the fourth power that's 81 but then
we have to multiply 81 times 7 81 times
7 so we're going to get 567 that right
81 times 7 7 times 1 is 7
7 times 8 is 56 so we're going to get
minus 567 over 4 this is going to be
really painful to do the arithmetic part
but we'll we'll power through it and
then we have 5x to the third X to the
third is 27 27 times 5 is 100 and 135
let me just I don't want to make any
mistakes
27 times 5 7 times 5 is 35 2 times 5 is
10 yep 135 so plus 135
135 and then finally we have minus 9x
squared so x squared is 9 times 9 is 81
so minus 81 over 2 so that's all that's
all of this business evaluated at 3 and
from that we're going to subtract it
when it's evaluated at 1 so we're going
to subtract when it's evaluated at 1 and
we get let's do this
so we get 1/5 1/5 minus 7/4 minus 7/4
minus 7/4 plus 5 plus 5 and then minus 9
halves minus 9 halves minus 9 halves and
what are we are left with is just a
really hairy fractions problem so I will
just hope that I don't make a careless
mistake at this point so let's try to do
this this is going to be equal to 2 pi
times and if we wanted to find a common
multiple here it looks like it would
have to be 20 least common multiple of 5
and 4 and 2 is 20 so this is going to
give us so 2 43 over 5 is the same thing
243 times 4 243 times 4 is going to give
us 3 times 4 is 12 4 times 4 is 16 plus
1 is 17 2 times 4 is 8 plus 1 is 2 plus
1 is 9 so we have 9 72 9 72 over 20 and
then we have to multiply 567 times 5 so
567 times 5 so you can see the
arithmetic is the most painful part here
7 times 5 is 35 6 times 5 is 30 plus 3
is 33 5 times 5 is 25 plus 3 is 28 so we
have 28 35 28 35 over four and then 135
over 20 well 135 times 2 is going to be
270 and then times another 10 is
700 so plus 2700 over 20 did I do that
right yeah that's right and then finally
81 over 2 is that's going to be the same
thing as negative 810 negative let me do
that same color negative 810 negative 8
10 over 20 numerator denominator both
multiplied by 10 and then let's see
negative 1/5 that's the same thing as
negative 4 20s and then negative or it's
going to be positive 7/4 it's it's the
same thing as positive 35 20 it's and
there's going to be a negative 5 a
negative 5 is the same thing as negative
100 over 20 and then finally the
negative nine-halves is the same thing
as negative 90 over oh sorry it's going
to be a positive I don't make that
careless mistake I'll make sure I get
the signs right after distribute this
negative is going to be a positive 9
halves which is the same thing as plus
90 plus 90 over 20 did I do all the
signs right negative 1/5 positive for
this one so then positive 7/4 negative 5
and then positive 90 over 20 and so now
I just have to do some hardcore addition
so let's let's do it
so first all I'll take all of the
positives and then I'll subtract out the
negatives just to simplify it so I have
to minimize the number of times
well I'll add all the positives together
then I'll add all the negatives together
and then that'll make it one subtraction
problem
so if 972 plus 27 hundred plus 35 plus
90 so let me just write it down so this
is 2700 plus 972 I should probably take
out a calculator at this point but well
yeah I'll just do it by hand since I've
already done it so much of it by hand
Plus 972 plus 35 or plus 90 plus 35 gets
us 2 so we get a 7 7 plus 9 is 16 plus 3
is
19 I do that right yeah 16 plus 3 is 19
and this is 17 and this is a 3 so we
have 37 97 when we added all the
positive numerators and then all the
negative numerators let's see I'm going
to add them together to see how negative
so 28 35 810 4 and 100 so if I add 28 35
810 4 or let me see 100 104 these are
all going to be this is how much
negative I have to subtract from that 5
plus 4 is 9 3 plus 1 is 4 8 plus 8 plus
1 is 17 and then you have a 3 so we're
going to subtract 3797 we're gonna
subtract 37 49 from 37 97 and so this
actually works out quite well that gets
us to 48 so this is equal to 48
let me make sure I haven't made a
careless mistake 28 35 810 104 those are
all the things I'm subtracting 20 709 70
to 90 and 35 or all the things I added
yep 3797 minus 37 49 is going to be
equal to 48 so this whole expression we
deserve a drum roll now is going to be
equal to 2 pi times 48 over over 20 and
both 48 and 20 are divisible by 4 so you
get 12 12 over 5 my brain is turning
into mush now I'm becoming paranoid that
I've been making careless mistakes but
let's let's we're almost there so it
becomes 12 over 5 and so our final
answer 12 times 2 is 24 so it becomes 24
PI over 5 and we are done